HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
NANCY PELOSI CATCHING HEAT FOR
THESE COMMENTS ABOUT THE ECONOMY
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN TO ME IN MY LIFE?
THAT MEANS I NEED A BIGGER
PAYCHECK.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE, IT'S ABOUT
WAGES RISING IN OUR COUNTRY SO
THAT CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS
RESTORED.
>> TRUMP CAMPAIGN, AND YOU SAID,
YOU REMEMBER THIS.
I WILL NOT TOUCH
SOCIAL SECURITY, MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID.
BELIEVE ME, I'M NOT PAUL RYAN.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
$500 BILLION IN MEDICARE,
MASSIVE CUTS IN EDUCATION AND
NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
HE'S GOING TO WAR AGAINST
WORKING PEOPLE.
>> SAW A NEW FOX NEWS PULLOUT
SHOWS PRESIDENT TRUMP AT 44
WHICH MIGHT BE AT THE HIGHEST.
AND THE KEY DRIVER FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S HANDLING OF THE
ECONOMY.
THERE YOU SEE IT ON THE SCREEN,
I THINK IT WAS 52%.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE FACT
THAT LEADING DEMOCRATS FOR
PELOSI, SANDERS AND OTHERS, ARE
WILL LIKE, WHAT ABOUT WAGES.
THAT'S THE FASTEST WILL RISE IN
WHICH A SINCE 2009.
AND IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
FACT-CHECK YOU.
>> IT IS.
>> 0.3 IS THE LAST, SINCE HE HAS
BEEN PRESIDENT, WAGES HAVE BEEN
UP CLOSE TO 3% AND THAT'S A
FACT.
ALSO, CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS AT
AN 18 YEAR HIGH.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT PELOSI IS
TALKING ABOUT, WHEN YOU COMBINE
THAT WITH, THE JOB WAS NUMBERS
ARE DOWN, AND DIGNITY 13, THOSE
ARE JUST MADE TO ORDER
REPUBLICAN ADS.
WE WERE LAUGHING DURING THE
BREAK ABOUT IT, SHE COULD NOT
CUT A BETTER AD FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
NANCY, WE LOVE YOU.
>> SO KIMBERLY, BERNIE SANDERS
SAYS THIS IS A WAR ON WORKING
PEOPLE BEING WAGED BY THE
PRESIDENT WHO WANTS -- HE SAID
HE WOULD NEVER CUT MEDICARE,
MEDICAID OR SOCIAL SECURITY
INCOME BUT IN FACT HIS BUDGETS
LOOK INTENT ON DOING JUST THAT.
>> Kimberly: I THINK
BERNIE SANDERS HAS BEEN HAVING
TOO MANY CAFETERIA LUNCHES WITH
NANCY PELOSI BECAUSE THEY BOTH
SEEMED CONFUSED.
THEIR COMMENTS ARE ONLY HELPING
TO MOTIVATE THE PRESIDENTS
SPACE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF THEIR
ILLOGICAL COMMENTS AND
STATEMENTS.
WHEN YOU SEE AN ECONOMY BOOMING
LIKE THIS, YOU SEE WOMEN,
MINORITIES AND BLACKS ALL
ENGAGED IN THE ECONOMY, RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AMERICA WANTED.
THIS IS WHY HE WAS ELECTED.
YOU SEE HERE IS SOMEBODY LIKE
NANCY PELOSI WHO IS COMPLETELY
OUT OF TOUCH, DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE.
ONE GAP AFTER THE NEXT.
IF THAT'S THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ARE IN
BIG TROUBLE GOING INTO THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND GOING INTO
2020.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS RIGHT NOW,
THAT SOMETHING SUSTAINABLE IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC GROWTH.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE OUT OF TALKING
POINTS BUT THEY ARE NOT OUT OF
GAS.
>> Juan: DANA, GOING BACK TO
THE POLLING, WHEEZING COMING
FROM PELOSI IS AN ARGUMENT THAT,
WHEN PEOPLE DON'T HAVE WAGES,
THEY CAN'T PAY FOR HEALTH CARE.
THEY CAN.
FOR THE HIGH COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THEY CAN'T PAY FOR THE KIDS TO
GO TO COLLEGE.
ARE WE SEEING THE EVOLUTION OF
DEMOCRATS MESSAGING FOR THAT?
>> Dana: IT'S NOT LIKE SHE IS
MAKING GAS, SHE IS ACTUALLY
SPENDING MONEY ON ADS.
SO IF SOMEONE IS TELLING THEM
THAT THIS MESSAGE WORKS FOR
THEIR PARTICULAR VOTERS.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THIS
THAT THE REPUBLICANS JUST NEED
TO BE A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT IS, THE PRESIDENT'S
NUMBERS ARE BETTER, THE GENERIC
BALLOT IS BETTER.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE HIGHLY
MOTIVATED TO REGISTER NEW
VOTERS.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW THIS UNTIL THE
OTHER DAY.
IN THE VIRGINIA ELECTION FOR THE
GUBERNATORIAL RACE LAST
NOVEMBER, MORE REPUBLICANS
TURNED OUT TO VOTE FOR THE
ELECTION THEN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND STILL ED GILLESPIE LOST.
12% OF THE VOTERS IN THAT
ELECTION HAD NEVER VOTED IN A
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION BEFORE US
OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE VERY GOOD
AT FIGURING OUT WHERE TO GO AND
REGISTER NEW VOTERS AND GETTING
THEM TO THE POLLS.
NO MATTER WHAT THE ECONOMIC
RESULTS ARE, THEY CAN GET THEIR
PEOPLE TO THE POLLS MORE THAN
REPUBLICANS.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE VOTER FRAUD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: BY THE WAY, EXPECT TO
PLUS NINE IN TERMS OF DEMOCRATS
FOR A GENERIC PREFERENCE.
GREG, I WAS LOOKING AT THE POLLS
AND, OF COURSE PEOPLE WHO LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAY THAT ECONOMY
IS THEIR NUMBER ONE REASON FOR
LIKING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO I SAID, WHAT DO PEOPLE --
BECAUSE HE'S STILL UNDERWATER,
44 OR 45% APPROVE.
51% DISAPPROVE.
SO I SAID WHY DO PEOPLE
DISAPPROVE OF A PRESIDENT THAT
GREG AND JESSE AND KIMBERLY LOVE
SO MUCH?
>> AND DANA.
>> Juan: THE NUMBER ONE REASON
THAT PEOPLE DISAPPROVE IS HE
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
NUMBER TWO, HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
TEMPERAMENT FOR THE JOB, NUMBER
THREE, HE'S DIVISIVE AND RACIST.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I THINK YOU JUST POST A
QUESTION THAT YOU WANTED TO
EXPRESS YOUR OWN OPINIONS
WITHIN.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE LOSING,
DEMOCRATS ARE LOSING WHEN YOU
ARE MARKING LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
SO THIS WEEK YOU ARE MOCKING LOW
AND EMPLOYMENT, LAST WEEK YOU
WERE DEFENDING MS-13.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO NEXT,
COME OUT IN FAVOR OF MEASLES?
WHEN THEY SHOW HER, THE
CALIFORNIA LEADER, THE PICTURES
OF THOSE HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS
UNDER OVERPASSES IN CALIFORNIA,
SHE CALLS THEM CALIFORNIA